hey everyone this is Costa kutzki here
for chess.com and today I'm just going
to be talking about a form of tactic
which is known as the pin a pin is
really best described with an example so
let's just jump right into it in this
position here we have a pin along the E
file the white Rook is pinning the
Knight to the black king why do we call
this a pin well the Knight Le cannot
move if the Knight moves somewhere then
The Rook will be checking the King which
is
illegal this means that the Knight can't
move and thus is a target which white
can attack okay that's why pins are very
useful and a lot of strong players are
constantly looking to pin their
opponent's pieces when a piece can't go
anywhere when he can't run away from you
then it's very easy to just attack and
win it so what's the best move here for
white
okay there are a couple of different
ways to attack this Knight the best way
to exploit this pin here is to play this
move
d4 now you're attacking the Knight with
something less valuable this is not a
good trade for black but he doesn't
really have an option because this
Knight legally can't move so on the next
move white is just going to be winning
material let's take a look at another
example okay so the first thing I want
want you to do here is try to find where
the pin is an experienced player can
find a pin very easily because they're
used to what they look like and they can
identify them right away in this
position the pin is
here okay the white Bishop is pinning
the Black Knight to the queen here there
is a very important
difference in this position the piece at
the back end of the pin is the queen
whereas before or was the king so you're
not allowed to leave your king in check
but you're always allowed to hang your
queen right so pins are still useful
because it's not a very good idea for
black to just move his Knight away and
drop his Queen but that does give you
extra options in getting out of the pin
because you're still legally allowed to
move the Knight okay in this example
black has the option of playing Knight
G4 check black is leaving his Queen
hanging but what he's doing is he's
attacking a more valuable piece the
king white doesn't have time to take the
queen he has to deal with this check and
he can capture and now black can take
this bishop so this is just a concrete
example you're not always going to be
able to move your pinned piece and make
a check but that's just
one possibility you should look out for
if you're try trying to get out of a pin
okay in this position white here is a
very good move exploiting a potential
pin that hasn't been created white can
play Knight D6 Checkmate so the Knight
is giving check to The King The King has
no squares he can go to and this Pawn
cannot capture the
Knight because the White Queen would be
checking the black
king so because there's no way to get
out of check in the next move it's
Checkmate so that's another example of
how you can use pins to your advantage a
lot of times you can use the squares
that that piece attacks and exploit them
so even though this Pawn is threatening
the D6 Square once the pin is set up it
actually can't go there which makes its
control of it sort of
irrelevant as you find more and more
pins in your games you'll soon be able
to
recognize immediately how to take
advantage and exploit them okay so let's
take a look at the position we have in
front of you now
um you've probably noticed the pin
already Rook is pinning the bishop to
the other Rook so how can white take
advantage of this well you want to
attack the pinned piece right a good way
to do it would be Bishop
A6 okay black captures the bishop then
we win the rook and we're also going to
Checkmate the king another way to do it
would be to play Bishop
F3 attacking the Bishop from this
diagonal both options are fine but
actually we're setting a trap with this
move Bishop F3 black might want to play
E4 sort of blocking this attack but if
we remember how powerful pins are we
know that we can just play Bishop takes
E4 and it's the same situation the
bishop is pinned so he cannot recapture
our Bishop as you become more and more
acquainted with pins you'll also find
clever ways to get out of pins so let's
alter the position slightly and let's
say white tries the same thing with
Bishop
F3 so now black has the
opportunity to play Rook C8 and threaten
Rook C1 check followed by mate so white
doesn't have time to take this bishop
because he's going to get M it right
which means
that while he's defending against this
Checkmate you have time to move your
Bishop since it's no longer
pinned with that I'd like to remind you
guys just a few basic tips about
pins the first thing is that when you
have have pinned a piece of your
opponents then that piece can't move and
is very vulnerable to attack so you
should try to attack it next thing is
that if you're the one in a pen and your
piece is being pinned look for ways to
get out of the pin the most common way
is to simply just attack the piece that
is pinning your piece for
example if we have this
position and black sets up this pin here
a lot of times all you need to do to get
out of a pin is just to play here
attacking this bishop and once the
bishop moves then you can play here and
well you're out of the pin so I wish you
good luck in your
games and I hope you find this tactic
very
helpful thanks a lot for listening and
I'll see you around on chess.com